welcome to this video okay and again
before that the play quickly strategy
didn't work out but I somebody played
too badly in that game so let's see what
we got here a modern defense will see
three turns the line that I often
recommend to my students it's a very
very am decent option for why to play
very solid set up so M what here nitey
three maybe four ninety two goals during
the center okay maybe that was not the
right timing ed 5mm I had looks very
equal okay let's take him I had a very
similar game once and tournament chess
thence the International Master from the
Netherlands yeah it's feels very equal
hmm what I could understand I've done
something else I don't know maybe if I
take our queen a3 is not working but I'm
taking us right I guess to misplace the
Queen a little bit maybe now get the
bishop out so that Queenie of three is
maybe coming with a tempo or here for
rookie one we've got 96 actually that
would have been would have been a good
idea at least net one Bishop here I mean
not that it is that much in this
position but at least some idea what to
play for him okay here maybe this is 94
I am let me check 96 and night to e4
for possible Knight f6 it's got should
if I know that's not parade and so let's
try that 27 looks very normal I know 94
for Knight to f6
it's a bit awkward rook ta dis covered
so that's not working and you Bishop f5
this is the move I was worried about at
95 yeah here see for looks very normal
why isn't that an idea I don't know
night before not before I can take yeah
not quite sure of 95 helped him a lot I
had night c 5 by the way yep okay I have
to make sure that plane quickly this is
not I need to still at some moments
pause for a bit and think about a good
move ready if 95 was strong already
taking e6 was very strong actually okay
if he goes Knight B form I have 95 yes
that wins straight away and other night
moves Knight f6 is really a problem this
is one of those who moments i'm taking
this black resign yeah it was really a
bad position already i guess so how did
that how did that happen something
similar i once head on out in or any
game i think some something very
comparable okay ruki five is better yeah
I suspected this and this is a probably
equal yeah okay it must be equal before
what else should this be that's nothing
to hope for okay but with this engine
gives Bishop f1 interest
there are some interesting tactics here
for example i'm probably threatening
rookie 5 rookie 5c for picking up two
pieces for work the engine basically
gives what a big advantage here I mean
really really big if the bishop moves
that ETA takes six minutes not easy to
make a move yet if you go see six also
see Freud strong oh it's very strong ok
because I will take on da take on eight
that wins the piece basically amazing we
are then I'm really really in good shape
f6 94c 695 that's very good for water ok
so this obvious looking move wasn't
child you know T it's probably about
equal here 96 was an idea just just to
take this is got 225 that's an
interesting move hmm ok it is this this
and now my night is looking immensely
stupid so this was ok normal stuff and
now with this yeah and i went to t 694
so what does the computer want to go our
Bishop a2 we are I didn't even think of
the move but of course the engine is
yeah without any prejudice just
snatching this check hey I'm getting
this kind of thing ok aight given by the
comp mmm I don't get it I a queen evade
ok so if i take take we need success I
mean it that should be really nice this
position
yeah engine gives this morose slight
advantage to white whatever that means I
mean I definitely have some kind of
compensation here but it doesn't seem to
lose straight away I grabbing that pawn
looks very risky ok that was the
computer when our nights if I there I
went for this quite quickly but 95 is
just better looking at those two
critical spots akia and taking and just
something normal XC 4 and this is really
really weak chair ok this is not a bad
move while this is just I don't know
yeah kind of doesn't work at all yeah if
he goes back here like no like a normal
normal way to play it's night f6
actually can ok I'm wondering Bishop f5
there is Queen age 60 k and something
like this I'm going back and I'm happy
ok that's really okay very good yeah I
know it's just just a piece ok well
thanks for watching